have you started season two yet we start
next week you start next week like are
you just the greatest secret keeper in
the world at this point who and your
life is like I got the inside because I
know real well to be honest I tell my
mom every you do yeah she knows she's
great to tell because she won't remember
exactly just like I was asleep before
that's how I let it happen you boil it
down to a line that you can at least
tease fans with is there anything you
can say the first episode I think
there's a general idea of you know it's
either gonna go this way or that way
it's either gonna go Tina's gonna be
door number a or door be right I always
say that it's it's not the door that you
think it is you can never imagine what's
gonna happen please God I don't want
pain America right now with politics
everything else is any of that sort of
attitude or climate gonna creep its way
into the show and we're telling a story
about humanity not just in our country
yeah and I think that as long as we keep
doing that and being true to that then
yes it is going to naturally end up
following events that we'll see in front
of us Elizabeth and Margaret were in
Toronto last week for the launch of
audible Canada a digital library of
audiobooks which includes The Handmaid's
Tale this book has been just around you
know for as long as it has to just hear
it when somebody new is it where it has
a new life - it's so exciting you have
the feeling that when you were writing
it you were writing it for possibly
generations yet unborn yeah and now
they've been born right